what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing one of the darkest secrets in
the world of boku no hero a concept that
was introduced early on in the story and
yet it was only very recently that we
received new crucial information about
the artificial humans known as the no
moon information that completely changed
the game in boku no hero and information
that is absolutely critical for
predicting the ultimate fate of
shigaraki all for one Anuj eCos
experiments on the nomu have been going
on for many years and these experiments
have become increasingly important to
the story especially with the recent
introduction of multiple new overpowered
high and no moon so in this video I will
explain everything we know so far about
the various types of nomu and the
process that was used to create them and
I will argue that there is still more
crucial information that is yet to
emerge including information about
shigaraki kuru giri and the female high
and no moon once this information does
emerge it will change everything we
thought we knew about the world of boku
no hero and about all for once true
master plan so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the book and hero content on
this channel and you'd like to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime lord don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't want to miss our videos you really
have to go through the trouble of
actually clicking the bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
not youtube is still gonna bury our
videos even if you're subscribed it's
just the way it works you could also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar finally this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers everything
is fair game including the very latest
information in the manga so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned the basic info that
we have about the normal at first is as
follows the no mover created from the
corpses of dead people in most cases
criminals and these corpses
were somehow revived and infused with
multiple works by Yugi Coe and all for
one
the Noma that we meet initially appear
to be largely mindless they are
completely loyal to the league of
villains and they blindly carry out
simple orders given to them by the
villains themselves at first we weren't
sure whether all the quirks given to the
nomu had to be stolen from another
person and could only be used once or
whether the same quirk could actually be
copied and reused on multiple normal
later on in the story it was confirmed
that Yugi ko has the ability to copy
quirks and then give them to the nomal
and he doesn't even need to actually
steal the quirk in order to do it the
high-end nomu known as hood had been
given the same muscle augmentation quirk
as muscular even though musculars quirk
was never stolen that means that if
Fujiko can somehow get his hands on
someone with a strong quirk he can
somehow copy that quirk and save it
without having to take the quirk away
from its original user as the story goes
on we learned that there are many
different types of Nommo out there some
of them are fairly weak although still
stronger than the average human and they
might possess one or two different
quirks these lower-tier nomu also tend
to be a lighter color and they need to
be directly ordered to act because they
are mindless servants of the league of
villains a large number of these nomu
might cause serious problems for law
enforcement but in general they don't
pose much of a threat to experienced pro
heroes above these lower tier basic
normal we have the middle tier
these are Noma who are stronger than the
low tier and who tend to have more
colorful skin examples include the
flying nomu from the stained arc and the
crazy chainsaw nomal from the forest
training camp Ark again these no mu are
not too smart and they're able to carry
out just basic orders but they're
definitely stronger than the low tier no
by the way in terms of the flying nomal
or the winged nomu there was some
speculation that this was actually to
basa the grandson of dr. Yuji ko that is
the same boy who used to hang out with
Baku goal and his quirk
as having wings but this was before we
knew that you gqo can just copy quirks
and give them to the nomal so I believe
that at most you gqo copied his
grandson's quirk and gave it to this
nomu I do not believe that his grandson
was actually turned into a nomal so
among these regular nomu we also have
the upper tier these no more black in
color they possess multiple quirks at
once and they are significantly stronger
than the mid and low tier normal a good
example of the upper tier normal is that
black nomal from the usj arc and normal
like this one are believed to be
stronger than ten average humans put
together during the usj arc we saw that
a normal of this caliber can definitely
pose a serious threat to even top tier
pearl heroes and we know that all might
had to work hard in order to ultimately
defeat the usj noble but despite being
extremely powerful the upper tier norm
will still lack any sort of real
intelligence and they cannot speak they
seem to be just more powerful versions
of the mindless zombie nomu that don't
know how to do much else except follow
orders however the most powerful type of
normal was revealed during the pro hero
arc of the story and that is the high
end nomal the high end nomu seem to be
far stronger than even the strongest
upper tier normal and the high ends are
able to possess like half a dozen
different quirks at the same time as we
saw during the pro hero arc even the
number one pro hero endeavor struggled
to defeat the first high end that was
introduced it is later revealed that at
least twelve high end nomu have been
created by ug co and all for one and
some of these nomu have been shown in
action during the hero raid on jakku
hospital but the difference between the
high end normal and the other normal is
not just a matter of power the high end
nomu are far more intelligent capable of
coherent speech and they even seem to
have actual personalities personalities
which they inherited from the humans
that they used to be prior to being
transformed into normal the high end
normal are able to instantly identify
most top tier pro heroes just by looking
had them and some of these no more even
able to use complex strategy the
clearest example of this in my opinion
is when the female high end nomu
sometimes referred to as the woman
normal was able to immediately figure
out the nature and effect of aizawa's
quirk and she was then able to avoid the
effects of his quirk by escaping his
line of sight and what's especially
interesting about that scene with the
female nomu is how coherent and
sophisticated her inner monologue was as
she was figuring out the true nature of
aizawa's quirk if we didn't know that
she was a normal we would have thought
that this was the inner monologue of a
normal person and a pretty intelligent
person at that the female nomu is
definitely not a mindless servant and I
would argue that her intelligence is on
a totally different level than even the
other high-end normal like hood her
intelligence could be compared to the
other nomu that we still haven't talked
about in this video
a nomu that is so intelligent that we
didn't even realize that he was a normal
I am of course referring to kudo giddy
in reality kudo kitty is the very first
nomu that we met in the boku no hero
story we just had no idea that he was
actually a normal it turns out that kudo
giddy is a no Moo created from the
corpse of Oboro shear Akuma who was a
classmate and close friend of Eraserhead
and present Mike back when they were
students in ua unfortunately during a
fight against a huge villain all
Brashear Akuma was supposedly killed so
all this time Eraserhead and present
Mike thought that their friend had died
but we ultimately find out that ug
carnal for one somehow managed to get
their hands on oberus corpse and they
then used oh Burroughs body as a base in
order to create kudo GD oberus quirk
cloud appears to have been used as a
base for the creation of kuru Geary's
quirk warpgate all-for-one used his
unique ability to combine quirks in
order to combine cloud and various other
quirks to create what we know today as
warpgate so as it turns out this
overpowered and rare quirk was
not a naturally occurring quirk at all
it was artificially created by all-4-one
on top of being given the ability to use
warp gate the no mukuru Giri was also
programmed to take care of shigaraki and
to help him become a worthy successor to
all-4-one this explains Kudo giri's
undying loyalty to shigaraki even back
when he was in his annoying emo gamer
edge Lord phase when this big kudo giddy
reveal happened the biggest and most
interesting aspect of the whole thing to
me was this simple question how is it
possible that kuru kadhi is such a
highly advanced and intelligent normal
and yet he was created so long ago we've
only recently seen the high and known
will begin to make their appearance and
hood was the first nomu we saw who was
capable of somewhat coherent speech we
know that some of the other high ends
like the female know more even more
intelligent than hood and that's all
good but are we supposed to believe that
kudo GD was created back when Alberto
died which is like 14 years ago and yet
he is by far the most advanced no mood
that we have ever seen a nomu so
intelligent that we had no idea that he
was even a normal as I said before the
female gnome was intelligence might be
comparable to kuru Geary's but she was
literally just released from her tube
and the procedure that created her
wasn't even fully completed when she was
awakened so how is it possible that up
to the point of the pro hero arc nearly
all of the Nommo that we had met were
almost completely mindless and yet like
14 years prior to that a highly
intelligent normal like kudo giddy was
successfully created
if they could just create a normal in
the level of kudo giddy why would all
for one a new KO even bother with the
lower tier unintelligent no move in the
first place I would assume that their
research would only have progressed
further in 14 years so in theory it
should be much easier for them to create
highly intelligent nomu now than back
then when they first created kudo giddy
and yet clearly this is not the case so
what's the answer
what makes kudo giddy so much different
from all the other normal with the
possible exception of the female
although she was seemingly created many
years after cooter giddy I've talked
about this in other videos but my
personal theory is that Kudo Gibby's
base Oboro shirokuma
was not actually dead when he was
experimented on by the villains and
transformed into a nomal the other gnome
who may have been created from corpses
but I believe that all Burroughs body
was probably horribly injured and on the
verge of death but he wasn't actually
dead his death was faked in the hospital
records by Yugi Cole and then oh
Burroughs living body was used as a base
to create corroboree my theory is that
using live subjects to create nomu
instead of dead corpses is what allows a
no mood to become far more advanced and
intelligent than a regular normal and
that is why kuru giri is so unique that
is why such a highly intelligent nomu
was successfully created so many years
ago
despite the fact that the technology and
procedures used to create the nomu would
not have been nearly as advanced back
then as they are now I believe that the
female nomal may also be special she may
also have been created from a living
person rather than a corpse and if that
is the case I wonder who the woman whose
body was used for the creation of the
female gnome who actually was but the
female normal aside kuru kitty really is
the biggest mystery here but with the
recent developments in the story I think
that we are finally beginning to get the
full picture of what happened to Oboro
and what is about to happen to shigaraki
think about the procedure that you Chico
has been performing on shigaraki a
procedure designed to make him stronger
and probably boost his quirk as well
perhaps even give him multiple new
quirks and yet this procedure is being
performed on shigaraki while he is still
alive he is not a corpse or a nomal what
if this procedure that is being
performed on shigaraki right now is just
an advanced version of whatever was done
to Alberto in order to turn him into
kuru giddy the shigaraki case clearly
proves that this
can be performed on living people not
just on corpses so to me the only way to
explain why Kudo guty was such a highly
advanced normal even though he was
created so long ago is that conducting
the procedure on living people rather
than corpses makes it easier to infuse
that person with new quirks and
abilities provided that the subject of
the procedure actually survives the
procedure itself obviously getting your
hands on human live subjects would be
harder than finding some corpses so I
assume that that is why normal like kudo
getty are so rare i believe that this is
the dark secret above the no moon and
about shigaraki most of them may have
been created from corpses but others
like Kudo giri may have been created
from a living person the gnome who have
been made from living people like kudo
giddy and potentially the female normal
are more advanced than the Nommo who
have been created from corpses and
considerably more intelligent at the
same time it seems that a similar type
of procedure although likely even more
advanced has just been performed on
shigaraki and so the results of this
procedure once she got Aki finally
awakens will be earth-shattering
shigaraki will never be the same again
and neither will the hero society once
he finally wakes up please let me know
what you guys think how do you think
that a gnome who is highly intelligent
as kudo kitty was created so long ago
and do you agree with me that Oboro may
still have been alive when Yugi Qin
all-4-one performed the procedure on him
and if the highly intelligent no more
like Kudo giddy and the female gnome who
have been created using living people
then who do you think was the person
that the villains used to create the
female no move finally what kind of new
powers and abilities do you think that
she got aki is going to possess after
his procedure a powered up quark
completely new quirks or something else
please share your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to the channel or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification
well to turn on all notifications you
can also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime up
or patrons for supporting our work and
making these videos possible special
thank you to a friend a a disciple of
Lord we go himself another important
thank you to all of our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world stealers Dyson query know
a quiet respect but a heffa Jonathan
King deci d brandon Avila's and emperor
otaku finally i can't forget all of our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings Eldred Anatole
Cassatt Sookie I'm Hal Cruz I Sparky 65
cricket XP Ted no Ted Joe Stanton very
Gucci Alecia ahktar animal s 69 jessica
calif on Dino cam Ian water
Bonnie parks Zoda art 12 rothwyn de Ora
Emperor Mitch loves anime and JCCC waka
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]